représente la passion du football qui
nous l'avons, nous le voulons en amour
pour le football et il est notre plus grande idole
tous ceux qui veulent être joueur je pense
s'en est inspiré un jour pour me prêter
mon hommage à mon Dieu, n'est-ce pas
vrai le roi ne meurt jamais bien et pour moi
il n'est pas mort donc je suis juste venu
payer mes respects ici
notre roue de l'amitié a en fait un
peu qui peut-être senti et a un
un peu qui a laissé la même chose se produire
Je pensais que non. Je suis allé me ​​reposer
car la légende ne meurt pas, elle continue
Je vis dans le coeur de quelqu'un qui est amoureux
vraiment pour le foot
l'évolution du football représente le Jeu de
La taille du joueur représente le dribble
nous sommes très tristes, je pense
est la plus grande idole du football non seulement pour
Brésiliens, oui, mais pour le monde entier
nous savions qu'il souffrait
à cause de la maladie
Et il va beaucoup nous manquer, n'est-ce pas ?
C'est bien triste pour nous de savoir ça
droit de nouvelles qui est le roi du football Pelé